vous propose d'écouter a pris un
témoignage celui de daria bibi couvent à
une ukrainienne interprète traductrice
indépendants ne vivent pas kiev elle a
répondu à nos questions depuis une ville
située à l'ouest de la capitale
ukrainienne
en ce moment il y à mes amis qui se
cachent dans des dans des caves dans des
abris à kharkiv il y à mes amis qui
essaient de contacter leurs parents dans
la ville de sumbe et cette île où il ya
plus d'électricité il ya plus de
connexion ils ne savent pas si leurs
parents sur les cuisses cette nuit mes
amis qui est qui est de la résistance à
kiev mes amis et mon frère qui
s'organisent en bénévoles il y a des
amis qui ont déjà perdu leur maison
heureusement ils ont survécu écoutez moi
ici je suis en relative sécurité mais
c'est uniquement grâce 1 grâce à l'armée
ukrainienne qui qui résiste depuis déjà
dix jours à côté de kiev à côté de
sommeil de czernin give et voilà donc
moi en ce qui me concerne on a on a
réussi à fuir kiev le 25 le 25 février
mais encore une fois je dis je suis en
relative sécurité et
les russes il si on les arrête pas si on
est pas le cren si on ne couvre pas le
ciel le cren continue à être bombardé
les villes ukrainiennes continue à être
bombardés je ne sais pas si je vais
revoir si je vais revoir mes amis qui se
trouvent actuellement dans ces villes
qui sont bombardés il ya les quartiers
civils qui sont bombardés il ya des
ambulances des hôpitaux des maternités
qui sont déjà ils sont déjà détruite
donc moi encore une fois ici c'est
plutôt on est on est on est au calme on
a juste on est juste obligé de descendre
plusieurs fois par jour dans des abris
on entend des sirènes mais jusqu'à
présent ici il n'y a pas eu de
bombardement